avec le confinement s'est tous mis à la
cuisine mais pourquoi pleures ton quand
on épluche à l'oignon quand on coupe le
liquide qui se trouve à l'intérieur se
vaporise le gaz montée arrive au
voisinage de nos yeux ce gaz contient du
soufre qui réagit avec l'eau au contact
du liquide lacrymal essentiellement de
l'eau qui enrobe et protège nos yeux le
s'ouvre se transforme en acide
sulfurique
ça pique du coup aux pleurs pour se
protéger mais plus il ya de larmes
plus on active la réaction que j'ouvre
se transforme en acide sulfurique
s'applique encore plus et on pleure
encore plus c'est une chaîne sans fin
la solution couper l'oignon à proximité
d'un filet d'eau le gaz est piégée avant
d'arriver à nos yeux ou plus radicales
le masque c'est plus ridicule aussi mais
ça me permet de venir à bout de cette
capsule 2d confiné aller à de bain et
n'oubliez pas nous sommes confinés et en
restant lien si vous avez aimé cette
vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce
bleus gens réalisent une nouvelle chaque
jour alors pour ne rater aucune de ces
capsules 2d confiné abonnez-vous et
activer la petite cloche
merci à toutes et à tous et à demain